يستمر نزيف تسريح الموظفين في شركات
التكنولوجيا في العالم وفي احداث عملاق
تكنولوجيه يخفض الوظائف هذا العام شركه
كيفال التي اعلنت عن تسريحه 2000 موظف
خطوه ستؤثر على حوالي 7% من قوتها العامله
العالميه سيما مع تخفيضات المحدده في
اعداد الموظفين سيتم الكشف عنها قريبا
لحسب موقع اكسيوس الامريكي
هو بالفعل نزيف حاد في قطاع الشركات
التكنولوجيا الذي تعرض لصدمات كبيره بسبب
موجات التسريح بالجمله وتوجه الكثير من
الشركات الاعتماد على الذكاء الاصطناعيه
نحن نتحدث عن تسريح اكثر من
316,000 موظف في شركات التكنولوجيا منذ
2020 حتى الشهر الاول من العام الجاري في
الشهر الاول اي يناير الماضي تم تصليحه
اكثر من 75,000 موظف بحسب بيانات
المتخصصه في تتبع التسريح الموظفين من
شركات مثل امازون مايكروسوفت جوجل وغيرها
ارقام ضخمه بالفعل فما السر
[موسيقى]